tuvieron que pasar 12 días desde que
comenzaron las protestas para que el
presidente Ibrahim raíz y se dirigiera a
la nación iraní a través de la
televisión en el día de ayer en el cual
fue bastante enfático interesante que al
principio se demoró casi 20 minutos en
llegar al tema de las protestas y cuando
lo hizo fue enfático en decir que
aquellos que habían creado el caos en el
país tendrían que pagar las
consecuencias judiciales él dice que él
habló con la familia de maxa Mini que
era bastante triste lo que había pasado
pero que no iban a aceptar estos
disturbios que habían conmocionado al
país y siguen sintiendo que esto ha sido
motivado desde el extranjero algo que
indigna enormemente a esas mujeres y
hombres que han salido a protestar en la
calle motivados por la muerte de esa
joven de 22 años que había sido
capturada por la policía de laboral roja
raíz insistió que habían lugares
específicos que se iban a crear para que
los iraníes descontentos pudieran
protestar y hacer su reclamo sin embargo
eso ya lo habían propuesto en el 2018
sin ningún éxito Así que este discurso
no crea ningún puente con la población
indignada que está en la calle de hecho
se sienten mucho más lejanos del
gobierno y así lo decían hoy y se decían
las redes sociales y si bien algunas
protestas han ido mermando en muchas
ciudades del país la realidad es que
muchos piensan que ante cualquier otra
circunstancia pueden volver a estallar
porque la división y la separación entre
esta población el gobierno es cada vez
mayor